ده المشاهدين الكرام ما زلنا نتابع حيثيات
هذا اليوم المهم من العمليات العسكريه مع
الاعلان اعلان الجيش السوداني بانه انتهى
مما وصفه عمليه الصمود وانتقل الى عمليه
التمشيط عمليه التمشيط التي يقصد بها
الجيش السوداني تتركز طبعا بطبيعه الحال
في مدينه الخرطوم العاصمه ونحن نعلم ان
الخرطوم تتكون من ثلاث اقسام رئيسيه
الخرطوم بحري المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه وان درمان والخرطوم الجنوبي وهذه
هي التي تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى في العاصمه
السودانيه طبعا الحديث حديث الجيش
السوداني يرتكز بدرجه اساسيه على المنطقه
الجنوبيه الممتده من احياء جبره
والصحافات ووصولا الى المدينه الرياضيه في
المنطقه الشرقيه هذا المثلث الذي يربط بين
النيل الازرق المنطقه الرئيسيه المغلقه في
الشمال والنيل الابيض وصولا الى هذه
المناطق الجنوبيه هذه الاحياء هذا هو
المثلث التي تدور به العمليات العسكريه
السودانيه خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
مع التركيز وفق ما قاله مراسلون بان
العمليات العسكريه في المنطقه الشماليه
تقريبا قد توقفت او لا يسمع اصوات اطلاق
نار في هذا المربع المهم وهو المربع الذي
يشمل المطار والمراكز القيادات العسكريه
مثل القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه ومطار الخرطوم هذه المناطق
حتى هذه اللحظه تشهد هدوءا حذرا ويمكن
القول بان العمليات العسكريه توقفت مع
اعلان الجيش السوداني انه بسط سيطرته على
مناطق واسعه هنا وعلى احياء عندما نتحدث
عن هذه المناطق فنحن نتحدث عن مناطق صغيره
واحياء صغيره ولكنها مكتظه بالسكان
بالتالي العمليه العسكريه فيها عنيفه
للغايه يقول جيش السودان انه استعاد
السيطره على مطار الخرطوم بعد ان سيطرت
عليه قوات الدعم السريع خلال الايام
الماضيه وانه استعاد السيطره ايضا على
منطقه
قصر الجمهوري حيث كانت هناك جيوب لقوات
الدعم السريع متمركزه في هذه المناطق الان
العمليات العسكريه تتركز بشكل اساسي كما
قلنا في الصحافات وهي اكثر من حي في هذه
المنطقه الجنوبيه ومنطقه جبرا جبرا الشمال
وجبر جنوب وايضا منطقه المدينه الرياضيه
التي تضم مجموعه كبيره من الاسواق هذه
المسافه الذين نتحدث عنها من هذه المسافه
الى هذه المسافه نحن نتحدث عن حوالي عشره
كيلو متر هي التي تمتد فيها هذه
العمليه العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الجنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم لتكون هذه
المنطقه التي يضغط فيها الجيش السوداني
الان في عمليات التمشيط التي يقول فيها
ويبدو انه من الجنوب نحو الشمال مع
اطمئنانه الى حد كبير لانه استقرت الامور
في هالمنطقه الشماليه جنوبيه نهر النيل
الازرق الذي يرتبط بملين الابيض ويشكلان
سويا
نهر النيل الان الحديث يدور عن نقطه
اساسيه اخرى وهي العمليات العسكريه التي
تشهدها مناطق الشوارع ونحن نتحدث عن
شارعين شارع ستين لنخلي الخريطه شارع 60
الذي يمتد في وسط العاصمه هذا هو الشارع
الذي يشهد عمليات عسكريه عنيفه هو الشارع
الذي يربط من منطقه الجنوبيه العاصمه الى
الشمال وصولا الى المطار والمناطق الاحياء
العملياتيه المهمه لقصر الجمهوري هذه
المنطقه تحدثنا عنها وايضا يرتبط به شارع
اخر وشارع مدني وهذا الشارع الذي يخرج من
منطقه الخرطوم ويتجه الى الولايات
الجنوبيه الحديث الان عن الولايات
الجنوبيه ينقلنا الى هذه الخارطه من هنا
هذه الطرق التي تمتد نحو المناطق الجنوبيه
وتحديدا ولايه الجزيره تشهد ضغطا عمليا
مكثفا خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه لانه
هناك حديث على ان هناك محاولات لدفع قوات
دعم السريع
بحشود عسكريه او دعم عسكري قادم من الجهه
الجنوبيه لذلك يحاول الجيش السوداني قطع
الطريق في هذه المنطقه قطع الطريق على
امدادات قوات الدعم السريع التي قد تاتي
من المنطقه الجنوبيه وبالتالي يضغط الجيش
السوداني الى منطقه جنوب الخرطوم وايضا
يضغط باتجاه شمال الخرطوم حتى يغلق
المنطقه الرئيسيه الخرطوم على دخول القوات
قوات دعم السريع التي كانت قد دفعت
بتعزيزه طبعا قوات الدعم السريع تتركز كما
ذكرنا في اكثر من مناسبه تركز في المناطق
التي تشهد نزاعات المنطقه الشرقيه مثل
اردوغان ودافور وايضا ببعض المناطق
الجنوبيه صحيح الدعم السريع موجوده في
اكثر من مكان وهذا هو الذي يصعب العمليات
العسكريه على الجيش السوداني لان القوات
الدعم السريعيه هي جزء اساسي من المكون
العسكري وبالتالي هي كانت تتخذ من عده
مناطق حوالي سبعه الى عشر معسكرات لقوات
الدعم السريع معسكرات كبيره في العاصمه
الخرطوم وحده وبالتالي هذا الذي
مد امد هذه المعارك وما زالت المعارك حتى
هذه اللحظه مستمره لان القوات الدعم
السريع متواجده بشكل كبير في المناطق
منطقه الخرطوم وهذا الذي يزيد من اشتعال
هذه المعركه حتى هذه اللحظه كما ذكرنا
المنطقه الجنوبيه من الخرطوم هذه المنطقه
التي تشهد المعارك والجيش السوداني يقول
انه يبسط سيطرته شيئا فشيئا في هذه
الاحياء التي تشكل الركيزه الاساسيه
للعاصمه السودانيه